hello everyone and welcome back to the
semi-finals of the uh aimchess u.s rapid
knockouts it's lavona renault vs magnus
carlson and the first match we didn't
cover they were well fairly fairly short
to draws all four games but now the
second match is a is a lot more fighting
going on so already the first game is
very very enjoyable uh without further
ado let's check it out uh levon with the
white pieces opens with e4
we have e5 knight to f3 and now knight
to c6 single one goes for bishop to b5
the rue lopez is on the board
with a6 by magnus morphy's defense and
now bishop to a4 we have knight to f6 uh
and now castles uh we have bishop to e7
and rook to e1 so nothing out of the
ordinary here we have b5 bishop to b3
and here magnus just castles and now if
white were to proceed with something
like c3 then we would play d5 go for the
marshall attack and have a very very
enjoyable game but levon avoids this uh
being a martial player himself uh he
goes for a for the anti-martial
variation and
it's interesting magnus uh uh we covered
i think two games um where magnus played
the martial attack against the
anti-martial and and one uh but we will
see what happens here so here bishop to
b7 uh we have d3 and now rook to e8 so
both players just continuing development
bishop to d2 and now b4 later on you can
further strengthen the position with a5
uh bishop uh ba uh going to g5 now and
knight the a5 attacking the bishop and
preparing to strike in the center with
c5 so bishop to a2 of course levon
doesn't want to give up his light square
bishop and now there are a couple of
games where d5 was played right away but
magnus plays h6 here and it is now as of
move 12 that we have a completely new
game
uh so the bishop is attacked you either
capture it or or move back so bishop to
h4 and now d6 uh we have knight beat to
d2 this knight is now coming as usual uh
to f1 to e3 and then maybe d5 f5 uh
depending on what black plays we have c5
uh and now
uh well you could continue with that
plan uh first lavon trades uh uh this
bishop for knight so captures captures
uh and now knight the c4 and now if
magnus doesn't trade then one is going
to bring this knight to e3 and then
again d5 and f5 will be within its reach
so magnus trades here we have captures
captures and now just a5
uh so what do you do here well it's a
it's a fairly close position and no
points have been exchanged yet so a
knight will
be able to you know cruise around those
uh pawns more freely than for example
this dark square bishop as all of cross
and spawns are on dark squares so of
course uh
he he will try to utilize that we have
g3 g6 h4 and h5 now so completely
closing the position uh and not knight
to d2 again this knight is coming to f1
to e3 and so on we have bishop to g7 by
magnus knight to f1 and now bishop to h6
now this bishop is put on this beautiful
diagonal and now it's uh it's a very
useful bishop so queen to f3 uh and now
rook to f8 queen to f3 uh yes okay we're
attacking the f7 pawn uh but rook to f8
is definitely coming and then we're just
going to open up the f file so this is
what magnus plays we have knight to e3
and now rook to a7 uh this this rook
will now help out with the defense of
the of the seventh right but we're gonna
play king to g7 on pin here play f5 and
then at some point bring the other rook
over to the f file if possible so here
we have knights to d5 uh with some ideas
of maybe delivering knight to f6 check
but just king to g7 now the queen and
the king are guarding that f6 square and
you can finally play that f5 move so
rook to f1 and magnus now executes f5 we
have f5 e captures rook captures
attacking the queen here queen to e2 and
now bishop to c6
now the rook can uh also also join the
df file we have rook 8 e1 and now while
you could capture this spawn levon
allowed magnus to capture this to try
and get some some counter play maybe
with f4 but magnus ignores it and he
just plays queen to a8 now with uh
a double attack on this knight and you
can't really move the knight just
anywhere uh i mean there's only the e3
square available to you you could also
defend it with queen to e4 and queen t
t4 although really ugly is uh probably
the only move here for for lavon uh but
he went back knights the e3 also
protects against bishop to g2 but now
the position is completely lost for him
so feel free to pause the video and win
the game for magnus while i give you a
couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those who were able to do it
congratulations on finding this uh well
just incredibly unpleasant move for the
white queen and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is of
course bishop to f3 and now you can see
that carlson's bishop pair now is fully
operational and this queen really does
not have a good square queen to d2 was
played but now just d5 with a tempo on
the bishop then d4 is coming the knight
will not be able to move and that's it
so here you could try capturing this
with check it is possible but it doesn't
change anything g captures and the queen
is trapped there there's nowhere to go
for the white queen you're gonna have to
block with the rook and then we can even
further attack the rook with the d4 and
it's just again completely lost so after
d5 we have bishop to a2 by levon now
comes rook back to f8 uh there's always
time there's no way to unpin so d4 is
coming uh levon played c3 but still just
d4 there there's no way to
get out of this c calculus on d4 we have
e captures on d4 and now queen to c2
finally i'm pinning but now we just
capture the the three knight ek d
captures an e3 f captures an e3 and now
rook to c7 defending the pawn here and
uh well now the one is just a down a
piece and it will be very very difficult
to play this queen to c4 was played
but now bishop to g4 uh we have rook
capture sun f8 queen character sun f8 uh
and now d4 starting to push this pawn
the pawn cannot capture as the rook and
c7 would be hanging by just king to h7
bringing the king to the safety also
bishop to g7 will be possible in the
future so e for now
but bishop to g7 attacking the d4 pawn
and the problem is there's no good way
to avoid this if you could somehow get
those pawns somehow out the board then
you would have compensation for the for
the
extra piece magnus has
but here if you try something like e5
then it's just queen to f3 and there's
uh well all of this trouble uh is
impossible to
to avoid you would have to do something
like this trade queens captures captures
and then we would just capture here and
that's it e6 so we would easily block
this with rook to e7 uh there's no way
to make any progress here so after
bishop to g7 we have looked at f1
attacking carlson's queen but now bishop
captures on d4 with check
king the g2 now comes queen to c8 going
for bishop to h3 check uh so rook to f7
uh delivering this check uh rook
captures an f7 queen captures but the
king can just go to h7 or as magnus
played bishop to g7 we have e5 trying to
get that pass pawn up the board but here
magnus just played queen to f5 and he
was in this position on mu 44 that uh
levon arunian resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh problem is uh if you capture then uh
there's no way to make any progress if
e6 we're just going to play bishop to
here or bishop here and there's no way
to for this pawn to get across uh and if
not after queen to f5 you could avoid
the trait let's say queen to d5 but then
we just play queen to c2 with check and
now it doesn't matter what you do here
now king to g1 now we could capture here
we could deliver this check we could uh
force a queen trait so whatever we do is
completely winning here
uh so yeah magnus uh took a lead in the
match by winning the first game with the
black pieces uh and uh then two games
were drawn and then magnus again won in
the last game so magnus won their second
match and with it the entire match and
will be facing uh someone i will not yet
disclose to uh in the finals of the
ancient u.s rapid knockouts
so that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it i would like to thank aditya
parasarati
and vincent natalie for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here uh thank you for
watching and i will see you soon uh
continuing the coverage of this very
nice event as we are going into the
finals so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
weekend